ton papa est parti très tôt suis à la
suite d'une très lourde dépression
comment tu as fait pour pour gérer tout
ça parce que tu t'es retrouvé minnerath
est ce que tu dis et je veux tu t'es
retrouvé seul teddy voilà comment on
devient drôle quand on a vécu une en
faut une enfance pas drôle du tout parce
que c'est vrai que ce que tu dit dans
son livre
voilà on l'enlève tous lu ici et on
s'est dit déjà comment tu fais pour
devenir drôle tu t'es dit c'est le seul
moyen de m'en sortir
ouais sérieusement oui c'est à dire que
ce livre en fait c'est vrai qu'il y ait
débat
les premières pages sont très tristes il
ya plein d'anecdotes xta.l voilà parce
que je parle de la disparition de mes
parents successifs à de ton père ou à la
mère doit faire d'abord et après
tombèrent après et je crois que c'est le
livre le plus optimiste que j'ai voulu
vraiment faire un livre optimiser vos
livres hélas manqué cette partie est
très difficile est terrible mais j'ai
voulu montrer que quand on a des rêves
quand on a envie quand on a un truc en
tête moi c'était la radio la télé de
série à une région très tôt tu le dis et
voilà je n'avais pas bien quoi mais je
voulais en tout cas faire ce métier
amuser les gens il ya un moment donné il
faut se relever et je crois moi que
l'humour m'a fait voyager assez vite
c'est à dire très vite je me suis dit ok
on va essayer de prendre la vie avec
essayer de rire de choses qui sont pas
forcément drôle parce que moi je vivais
des drames à ce moment-là successivement
et et je crois que ça a marché je crois
que si je suis devenu celui aujourd'hui
qui se moque un peu de tout
qui des fois raconte des conneries plus
grosses que lui c'est parce que j'ai
pris à ces petits cette habitude de dire
voilà dans les situations vraiment
terrible qui peuvent arriver là il faut
essayer de trouver ce qui va nous sortir
la tête de l'eau et c'est ce que c'est
ce qu'on a ressenti alors tu parles de
ta maman tu as perdu à l'âge de 8 ans tu
dit aussi qu'elle était très dure avec
toi il fallait jamais pleuré devant elle
est-ce que tu essayé quand même de la
feria a non pas du tout gt gt gt un
garçon très calme j'étais un gars ont
assisté aux gentils fâcheux du souvenir
plutôt calme plutôt plutôt bon élève qui
voulait qu'une chose c'était que les
choses se passent bien à la maison et je
crois que j'étais ce qu'on pouvait être
le gamin le plus normale possible quoi
mais non et si je n'étais pas vraiment
un clown ni à l'école j'étais plutôt le
gamin le plus calme du monde un peu seul
dans son coin fils unique offre les
profs qui fait à imad aurais-je été
perdant j'avais des bonnes notes jetées
sympa et two way madoré un raise mot sud
heure là c'est comme maxime kenny devait
être comme ça non j'étais très sage ou
un élève moyen mais très sage
il est devenu très drôle aussi
ah c'est ton papa est parti très tôt
suis à la suite d'une très lourde
dépression comment tu as fait pour pour
gérer tout ça parce que tu t'es retrouvé
minérale c'est ce que tu dis et je veux
tu t'es retrouvé seul délit voilà
vraiment je suis je suis seul j'ai plus
personne vers qui me tourner ouais j'ai
eu ben oui ça a été quand on est fils
unique gym j'ai reçu plein de
témoignages avec ce livre depuis qu'il
est sorti depuis jeudi dernier de maman
j'ai vu encore des messages de maman
tout à l'heure qui m'ont dit le père de
notre petit garçon est partie et
quelques temps merci pour le livre de
gamme qui se retrouver orphelin voilà
qui me disent wow merci pour le livre
parce que ça veut dire que il ya la
suite derrière et c'est vrai qu'on peut
les avoir l'impression dans la vie des
fois quand un drame comme ça arrive tout
s'écroule
oui tout s'écroule mais tout se
reconstruit derrière moi je commençais
la radio depuis que j'avais 14 ans j'ai
un âge un peu anormal pour faire de la
radio
c'est quand en plus j'ai géré le le
décès de mon père etc
je devais continuer mon école de
commerce sans savoir vraiment comment
j'allais là a payé et continuent d'être
drôle à l'antenne le samedi puisque je
faisais de la radio le samedi donc très
très vite en plus je me suis raccroché à
ce métier et je pense ça m'a fait aussi
beaucoup de bien de me dire allez qu'est
ce que je vais pouvoir de trouver drôle
dans l'actu raconter aux gens cette
semaine pour les 20 ans alors que je
sais aussi pour sortir des gens parce
que tu le disais il ya plein de gens
aussi qui doivent avant de vivre des
moments difficiles comme moi j'ai envie
de les faire marie j'ai envie voilà deux
oui j'ai essayé moi pour moi lui mais je
dis amendé dans le livre mais je crois
que l'humour a sauvé ma vie mais c'est
vrai c'est à dire l'humour le décalage
de se dire on va prendre les choses
drive graves peuvent arriver mais il ya
faut toujours trouver cette dérision
quelque part alors tu dis à l'école
normale mandat plein de copains et toi
quand il y avait un match de foot
personnes y toi dans l'équipe le looser
tient le vilain petit canard et il est
là tu te tue ça t'a marqué ça ça te
plaît ou pas mais parce que j'étais un
gamin j'étais un gamin seul qu'elle ait
pas une confiance alors et je n'avais
pas une grande confiance en moi j'étais
loin d'être beau j'étais un peu gros
j'étais donc je passe je vais pas dire
ce mot à la mode que l'on entend que
harcèlement parce que parce que ça
existe beaucoup mais j'ai pas su bien
c'est manger du j'ai dû me renforcer un
petit peu parce que quand on est un peu
pas le logo
les filles viennent pas j'étais pas le
chef de bande j'étais plutôt plutôt très
timide dans mon coin voilà
mais j'ai décidé en grandissant et la
radio m'a donné une grande confiance en
moi parce qu'avec le micro je me cachais
derrière j'avais 13 ans et louis 14 ans
on pensait que j'en avais 20 22 puis je
commencer à raconter des conneries
énorme et ça commençait à faire rire
finalement je commençais à prendre un
peu d'assurance et ben en tout cas
aujourd'hui voilà je te le dis et je le
dis très souvent dans cette émission
était devenu un des plus grands
animateurs voilà français je te le dis
et même pour moi tu fais partie du
vraiment je te le dis de deux des
meilleurs parce que en impro j'en ai vu
des animateurs est vraiment été
impressionnant est vraiment et de mettre
sous la dent d'animation il y en a un
tous les dix ans voilà et c'est vrai que
arrêt exceptionnel fait partie des rares
animateurs ont conduit hier soir tu as
pas regardé l'émission tu as regardé
cauet s'est laissé la marque en lui même
sur quatre cauet
[Musique]